[Music]
[Music]
that is wild anyway episode number 201
Vinnie just uh taught us something
that's going on with vitamin the
Instagram account maybe we'll ask you
guys for you to test it out as well got
a lot of things to talk about yesterday
our commander-in-chief of the world
president uh Joe Biden gave a uh Speech
26 minutes I don't know if you guys had
a chance to watch it I watched it last
night uh we'll talk about that uh hikes
fed uh approves another three quarters
of a basis point
um which takes it high since 2008 and
hence a change in policy ahead uh we
looked at mortgage rates folks you're
going to be surprised with the average
person let's just say the average person
what is the average person's FICA score
give me a number for FICO score seven
six six one eight a.m 720 thing is
average that's like six okay 680. okay
so let's just say 700 680 fine if
somebody's got a 650 FICA score you're
going to be surprised by what the
interest rate is going to be we'll look
at the breakdown Tom pulled it up this
morning uh we'll talk about nearly 40
percent of small businesses in the US
fail to pay rent in October let me say
that one more time how scary that is
nearly 40 percent of small businesses in
U.S fail to pay rent in October that's
pretty scary to think about and why are
they not paying rent shouldn't they be
making money isn't unemployment the
lowest it's been shouldn't people have
more money than ever before why are they
missing out on rent forty percent of
them that's a big number it's not a
recession no it's not a recession and
then it's Putin officials Saudi tells
U.S that Iran May attack the kingdom
we'll look into that Twitter employee
been sleeping at uh on the floor as Elon
Musk pushes tight deadlines it's a very
depressing environment over there by the
way tomorrow's going to be Black Friday
for Twitter if you haven't heard I think
they're gonna fire possibly 50 of the
workforce and then you got some other
studies that came out about drinking
about musk about White House the leading
a tweet uh Vinnie's got some stuff to
say about Paul Pelosi we got a bunch of
different things to talk about and to do
that with us today will be Adam will be
Tom Ellsworth and will be Vinnie oshana
how you guys doing how you feeling I
feel fantastic I try to sketch yesterday
with your kids and it was absolutely the
craziest one hour I've had enough they
behave were they good listen the problem
was I heard they had no sweets I don't
want to give it away because we're going
to post it tomorrow but it was candy
kids and then you say action and be
crazy and to say all right guys cut go
back to normal it was I saw MAV who's uh
one of our you know guys in the editing
production he's a [ __ ] guy he's a
very good looking guy he looking back
I'm telling you
today was the day he literally was like
I'm not having kids yeah I said I'm mad
do not judge kids based on their David
kids no no no very different climate
yeah
your kids are probably gonna be like you
chill easy going so Mavericks should
have a lot of these kids
the mine are gonna be like what are you
kidding me you cannot give those kids
yeah
so so let me say let me say a couple
things uh gang I want you to be thinking
about so we um we didn't really make a
big deal about the 200 podcast because
moving forward it's not going to be 200
300 400 it's going to be based on
subscribers at 500 000 subscribers we're
gonna do a live live podcast that you'll
be able to come attend and see it live
with 200 people at our new studio that
we've built which is sick so stay tuned
in about a week or two we'll be selling
those tickets for people to buy because
it's limited seating only and those who
buy the tickets it'll be in Fort
Lauderdale you'll be with us live when
we cross 500 000 Subs we'll do live
podcasts together with a guest or two or
three or who knows but we'll have a good
time can we give a quick shout out to
everyone that's working on that other
Studio I mean freaking ridiculous oh my
God are you kidding me Jorge you got rob
you got uh Eric Eric you got a bunch of
guys that are working on a job anyways
let's get into it okay Tom so fed
approves three quarts of basis point
High to rate uh take rates to highest
since 2008 hints at change in policy
ahead this is a CNBC story and a
well-telegraphed move the markets have
been expecting four weeks the central
banks raised its short-term borrowing
rate to three quarters of a point to a
target of 3.75 to 4 Points the highest
since January of 2008 the move continued
the most aggressive pace of monetary
policy tightening since the early 1980s
the last time inflation ran this High
the new statement hinted at the policy
chain saying when determining future
hikes the FED will take into account the
cumulative tightening of monetary policy
the lags with which monetary policy
affects economic activity and inflation
and economic and financial developments
economists are hoping this is much
talked about step down in policy that
could see a rate increase of half a
point in December meeting and then a
smaller fewer hikes in 2023 this caused
the market they announced this late and
a market tanked it went from being down
20 points to being down 500 points
within literally I think 30 minutes or
so so Tom when you see this what are you
learning with this rate hike they
announced yesterday well what you have
to remember is when they say what when
the typical person reads well Telegraph
what that meant was the banks that make
the mortgages were expecting this
because remember the mortgages move at
the bond market and the mortgage-backed
Securities and what the average person
needs to understand is that the interest
rates affect those first then the
mortgages so the mortgages about a week
ago were sitting there like 7.375 which
is seven and three eighths to seven and
a half is where they were and this
morning I went in there and I looked and
I said what are they adjusting because
they had built in some of this
three-quarters of a rate increase but
what they heard Powell say is there's
probably another half Point coming in
December and so that moved things this
morning and I looked it up
if you're a person typical in the United
States we were just talking about this
hold it up type in Google mortgage rates
yeah mortgage rates today and you'll get
the uh and by the way Tom you have to
realize this three quarters of a basis
point increase doesn't take into effect
with rates for another week or so so
people are going to see an increase next
week maybe the following week yeah so go
ahead perfect this is it right here now
move the credit score just take it down
to 680 690
at
7.891 you are knocking on eight now
let's say I've got a little bit of
credit card debt and I've had things
going on during the pandemic just take
me to 650. not need not anymore than
that but just rent to 650. terms 8.327
so the banks are drawing a line if you
are below 650 right now which is not
horrible credit below 660 if you're
below 660.60 not horrible credit you are
at eight and three eights three seven
five that's where you're sitting right
now which means this is put in
perspective now we're talking rates and
everything and let's put it for the
typical person you bought a house Vinnie
yeah last March say for half a million
okay three and a half percent loan
your payment Was Eighteen hundred bucks
pretty reasonable I would that's my rent
now if you try to buy that same house
right now five hundred thousand dollar
house four hundred thousand dollar loan
and you go out and you get a seven point
eight percent interest rate it's three
thousand dollar payment on the nose
twelve hundred dollars more which means
and if and if you said to your bank but
I can only afford eighteen hundred and
they said okay that's fine just go find
a house that's worth three hundred and
ten thousand dollars oh wow do you see
what just happened for your same
eighteen hundred bucks with that
interest rate yeah so that is a ladies
and gentlemen a 40 drop in buying power
for the American Consumer it's real this
is not speculation this is not patent
Tom talking about the future this is
reality right now so if your job is
moving you to another area people have
said in the comments well what do I do
you know what's in it for me what should
I do
if your job is moving you from one part
of the country to the other first of all
you're going to have to Discount your
price on the house you got right now
it's probably up a bit get out from
under it and then under consume housing
on the other end get yourself a lease
and get small space make the kids share
a bedroom for a year and a half two
years and that's how you're going to
have to weather the storm you don't have
any choice on it go lease lease less
don't let your pride and your you know
it's crazy time you're saying this
you'll be back yeah you'll be back but
just surf it out I gotta so I get when
we anytime we talk about things like
this a lot of friends and family and
people that follow the content that are
loyal to it who are in the real estate
and Mortgage business they message us
listen and here's how it all starts Pat
I love all your content except
you've been going after us realtors for
too long man and this is like not cool
and I'm like look I understand you're
not happy about what we're talking about
but here's what I will tell you with the
current messaging that we got going on
this is here because of printing fake
money for too long yesterday Tom and I
were talking I said okay when is the
next time rates are going to be around
five percent okay so we're actually
doing the math together so then we pull
up and we say okay how long is this guy
going to be in the the chair of a Fed
Powell well he got elected when May of
last year 20 May of this year 2022 by uh
Biden because you need because he
doesn't he doesn't really report to the
president but you need the president and
certain amount of people to get him to
say we want you to stay as a chair of
fed right Senate votes him in yeah the
Senate and the president's the Trump
Administration he was he was so he was
re-elected but but the point is the
point is reelected Not Elected right he
was he was re-elected by Biden so Biden
kept them in so this is not a Republican
or a Democrat type of guy this is a guy
that both of them are like dude he's not
listening to me he's not listening to me
what he does how's the veggies shoot me
you're right so he doesn't take Council
from Trump he doesn't take counsel from
Independence we like that you you as the
consumer believe me we don't have enough
people like that yeah you know when his
next term is going to be up it's going
to be May of 2026 which means the next
time rates are going to be at around 5
it's probably going to be Q3 or Q4 of
2026 if that and this six percent above
could stay for a long time and that can
become the norm here's the challenge
this morning I was looking up an article
by Wall Street Journal I want to send
some of these pictures to you and I
don't know if you guys knew this or not
but Federal Reserve has assets and
liabilities okay they have both assets
and liability on their balance sheets
basically the fourth branch of
government if you want to think of it so
when you say they buy their own
company their company so Tyler I'm gonna
airdrop this too if you can pull this
that goes down to the premise of
quantitative easing quantitating
tightening that's how they kind of limit
the money my nose is going to bleed but
quantitative believes but typically
typically what they've done they've
stayed very neutral it's been very
neutral so all of a sudden when they
start if you can pull this up I don't
know if you see it or not if you got it
uh I want to show this it's very
insightful on how to Fed works pull up
all three of them if you can so go go to
the first one I sent okay zoom in a
little bit that's the balance sheet the
other one the balance sheet of go to
yeah the balance sheet of the FED here's
what you're looking at zoom in a little
bit if you can I don't know if you can
or not so okay here we go on the asset
side they have 5.61 trillion dollars of
U.S treasury Securities t-bills tables
exactly short-term bills okay and then
they have 2.69 trillion dollars in
mortgage-backed Securities that's the
MBS I talked about that's right that's
what you saw in big short so again 2.69
trillion mortgage-backed Securities is
it is it the same way to explain time
like a reinsurance right like how Munich
reality smaller insurance companies they
go to a Swiss tree and they're the in
Insurance the reinsurance that's backing
them up so 2.6 trillion dollars it's the
Jenga scene from The Big Short
yeah
that's right and then other that have
0.48 trillion which means they have
roughly 8.78 trillion dollars of Assets
Now liabilities currency and circulation
which is interesting because currency in
circulation is 2.28 trillion dollars
okay Reserve balance
3.04 trillion dollars and other is
another 3.46 trillion dollars for total
of eight point seven eight trillion
dollars okay go to the next one this is
the scary part of what's happened to
them go to the one priority that I just
showed you yeah right there so the
earnings of Federal Reserve sent to U.S
treasury for the last 12 years okay if
you look at that this is the first time
they're in the negative how is the
Federal Reserve in a negative do you
realize for 11 years straight this is
very interesting fact for 11 years
straight the Federal Reserve has netted
four to eleven four to ten billion
dollars every month let me say that one
more time every month the reserve the
Federal Reserve has netted four to ten
billion dollars except for this month
look what happened right there boom drop
off and then something bad happens yes
and then if you go to the other one I
sent you I don't know if you got another
one or not there was a third one I
wanted to show you which is very very
interesting when you look at this I'm
sending it to VT MacBook Pro so just
come straight to you I don't know if you
see it or not if you got it and there
you go there you go if you can pull that
up check this out so this is how it
looks okay the green if you look at this
the green is treasury Securities cool
the light green is mortgage-backed
Securities at the top
the dark red is currency in circulation
and the light rate is bank reserve and
then white is other right go prior to
2008 prior to quantitative easing it's
very normal not a big deal they didn't
get involved they just kind of weren't
there you know they didn't do nothing
they were not manipulating the market
they were not manipulating the economy
and then they say there is this thing
called quantitative easing let's get
involved so they got involved oh [ __ ]
okay now we're in too deep and in 2020
oh [ __ ] covet oh what are we doing now
now it's like getting off of this this
is why when people sit there and they're
like
no this is not gonna happen realist is
not going to take dude there isn't a
better definition of fake success for
this many years and Powell who right now
has got a very very hard job because
anybody that's hated by Republicans and
Democrats is probably the most honest
man in America okay this guy is not
Direct by anybody yeah no one likes this
guy the left doesn't like him the right
doesn't like him heck the people in the
middle are confused they don't know if
they like this guy or not but all he's
saying is guys we can't go like this for
too long so Pat somebody that somebody
like me that doesn't I mean Tom has
sheets he's gonna have a bullet point
presentation in five minutes I don't
know for someone that doesn't know so
when they printed all this money now
they're hiking up these rates Tom
because they want to make their money
back is that what it is and we're all
suffering because we're not in a
recession but we're on a recession what
is how would you explain to somebody of
how they can hike up a percentage for
mortgages and we're going to be
suffering because they [ __ ] up so what
happens if inflation goes High who's
affected by we are who's everybody
everybody
but the rich people are rich people
affected by it they'll be all right are
they they'll be just fine they're gonna
be fine they're affected but they're not
they're not decimated he's right Zuck
losts 100 billion dollars but he's
chilling yeah but by the way a lot of
These Guys these big big billionaires
that I'm talking to guys that were worth
50 billion and up 100 billion and up you
know this year they've lost roughly a
half a trillion dollars of wealth okay
well that's because during 2020 they
gained uh 10 trillion well something
ridiculous but exactly but the point is
that should that's normal that's okay
for that these these billionaires are
gonna be okay
all I'm saying is the guys the guys that
went up yeah and made that fake money
because of covet that money is gradually
disappearing okay so if if if the
average person cannot go out there and
say dude how the hell am I supposed to
be paying for this stuff
that is not good for anybody because if
they can't make their bills if they
can't pay their bills then crime goes up
then divorce rates goes up then drugs
goes up then alcohol goes up then
everything goes up now you have you now
you have a bad situation here so they
got to figure out a way to control
inflation and unfortunately feds cause
this mess trying to fabricate the
economy from dropping the way it did in
08 now they're trying to kind of
backtrack it's kind of a shitty
situation there I just realized
something I just went into my back
pocket I think we're good because the
Powerball was 1.5 okay
even look yet yeah we have nothing to
worry about yeah we're good
wait who's the winner who's the winner
in Florida where because I'm not looking
about this no I haven't anybody I have
bad news bro what you didn't win how do
you know what are your psychic Tom you
didn't win the bill don't break this
puppy is one thing yeah and for the
average person to understand and the
average person on the street you can
explain things in simple terms they
would know I I put the um that that
chart back up the the length chart was
extending that one so
just look at a picture okay
look look what was happening the last
two years of the Trump Administration he
was trying to address this and do you
see how it was squeezing fun yeah yeah
it was about to squeeze back in because
the Trump thinkers knew that we needed
to get back to pre-2008 and the policies
they put in take a look yeah it was
squeezing back and then the whole thing
goes off rails with covid and we printed
money so you can say what you will that
you should never leave Trump
alone in a room with your daughter which
I agree with but I'd love to leave him
alone I'd love to leave him alone in the
room with the economy because good
things appear to be happening and you
have to take a look at that and you have
to give credit to the administration
that was there you don't have to like
Trump but if you look at the picture you
have to look at the picture and say what
were they doing they were trying to
start a trend to get back to the center
line of financial sanity so that
wouldn't be the interest rates and it
wouldn't be the inflation happening to
the average American and now the the
best analogy I have for it is when you
get cancer chemotherapy sucks but why do
we go through chemotherapy and radiation
because it'll kill the cancer right we
are going through increased interest
rates and other things that the FED is
doing because unfortunately that's the
cancer cure for inflation and it sucks
and we all have to get through it
together and all the analogies are there
you may lose your appetite you may lose
your hair but this is what we're going
to have to do to get the economy to come
back into a center of thing and it and
it sucks most of all for middle class
people and do you do you guys think uh
uh like a political shift would would
start changing that the other way like
if a republican went in the Santa
whoever is that going to start changing
if the politicians have the theological
view of the economy like this then that
helps okay I'll uh
I'll try to extrapolate
so you posted something on your
Instagram the other day regarding uh
Milton Friedman I actually watched it
multiple times I think was very telling
and then we've talked about the steroids
analogy as well
I'll try to kind of give an analogy
break it down and then what basically
every day people should do so Pat talked
about Milton Friedman basically
comparing alcoholism and getting drunk
to printing money and uh essentially
that the short term and there's
long-term benefits of stopping drinking
like if you're an alcoholic and you stop
drinking like short term you're gonna go
through uh withdrawals withdrawals
seizures like all the sweating the
disgustingness but long term you're
gonna be better right same thing with
steroids if you're on steroids just like
printing money if you're on steroids
instead short term your body's gonna
just like be what the hell just happened
here especially when you stop using
steroids but long term they'll look good
for a minute exactly so same thing with
printing money is that if you're just
printing money okay short term
everyone's got money this is great the
economy but long term it's a mess and
the exact opposite situation when you
stop printing the money short term
there's going to be this nonsense there
that we're seeing right but long term
are we better so that's essentially the
macro perspective on printing money it's
not good I mean the money we talked
about this all the time the money the
more money you print you thank you
Milton Friedman clip yes
I think that's a great word and I think
the printing the money Adam not the
don't forget your thought they're
printing the money during the covet I
understand we needed the people needed
the money bro especially I was in LA
acting everything comedy done we needed
it but they've continued to keep paying
people number one and then we spent how
many trillion did that that's what you
mean by printing more yeah of course
the first cares act under Trump was 2.2
trillion and then Biden came in with the
whole situation he printed another three
trillion but stop printing money was it
close to the rich people the question
that you asked when you asked Tom and
Tom said Trump tried to uh address it
the economy at the end he says you know
you may not trust him what did you say
you may not trust him in a closer room
with your daughter but you could sure
trust them with the economy and he had
to close
look look when you when you think about
like somebody who comes into you buy
small business and there are people that
buy businesses that are struggling
businesses there's a model these are
people that come in and say hey you're
dying you're struggling but it's a good
business it's a good product you just
are making some bad decisions operators
are bad there are people that Target
businesses like that the first thing
they do when they come in they look for
Waste expenditure they get rid of it
they look for wasted hiring like Elon
today's tomorrow is
set to be firing 50 percent of his
employees okay he's an operator he comes
in he's letting go fifty percent cost
expenses you know whatever he's doing
with the verification aoc's not happy
about it he says no problem you don't
like it thank you for your input but now
pay eight dollars a month right yeah
beautiful so he says and then he
explains to the other guy who was the
other guy that was on this like yeah I
can't believe you're charging eight
dollars listen you have to figure out a
way to run a business we got to make
some money that's what you got to do so
a logical thinker like that can fix this
economy in no time logical thinker can
fix this economy in no time yesterday
Biden's speech you know what Biden's
speech was the first thing he talked
about so you know how when you're doing
a video on YouTube what's the most
important part of a video you put on
YouTube what's the most important part
of a video first three seconds first
three to five seconds you don't get them
the first three to five seconds you lost
them yeah like I said it's over like
stand-up comics it is so important on
how you catch my attention yeah you know
what's the first thing he talks about
what
the first thing he talks about is
popolosi okay and the threats of them
the hammer yeah and then talks about the
mega Republicans and talks about
elections like you know the whole
message was around people that are going
to question the elections and you're
sitting there you're like okay rates
just went up three quarters of a basis
point yesterday okay the Market's where
it's at people are concerned and the
only thing he wanted to talk about was
elections for midterms the entire time
in papalosi 23 minute speech 22-minute
speech whatever the timeline was that's
all he talked about and now they're
saying that the elections midterms that
are coming up don't expect Real Results
for a few days and then Brazil did you
guys see the guy that won can you pull
up the picture of how many people
protested in Brazil yeah have you seen
the picture
how many people go to Brazil protesting
this this socialist was a criminal who
won do you know who's getting involved
do you know who's getting involved to
say you can't question the election
results uscia the director of CIA here
one of the leaders of the CIA here went
to Brazil
to deal with their elections and now
America is saying it's a fair election
we can't say anything about it and the
voters are saying no I don't know if you
count on my votes or not so here's
here's where you go with it if somebody
is sound
who's coming in saying a logical thinker
who can sit there and actually come up
with policies that are good this can be
fixed in four years the economy it's not
going to take one year it's not going to
take two years it's going to take four
years and you don't just do it suddenly
it's got to be very you know a
methodical way of you doing it and
Powell's trying to do it he's doing his
best to do it it's not easy what he's
doing right now it's a terrible job that
he's got but the challenge more
importantly is we don't have the right
leadership right now to fix this economy
because what they're thinking about is
midterm elections Paul Pelosi and
dividing America and more pinning
everything on Republicans knowing
they're afraid that potentially they
could lose New York they could lose
Arizona they could lose all these states
they are so scared that they're saying
we need two three days look you know
when when you have a friend or you're
you're dating a girl you're dating a guy
or you have a business partner if a
person is sitting there saying dude I'm
telling you you know they're constantly
saying I would never do that I would
would never do that I would never do
that I would never do that I would never
do that maybe you would do that you know
or somebody who was keeping a area that
they don't want you to look at you can
look at anything but not that we can
talk about anything but not that we can
talk
when the police officer said there's
nothing to see here there's definitely
something to see there so so when
politicians tell you there's nothing to
look at with Brazil elections there's
nothing to look at with midterm
elections there's nothing to look at
with this listen man I have a hard time
trusting any of these politicians that
taxpayers are paying because they think
America's theirs and America is the
people's country that's what it is and
and I think more Americans today are
starting to realize this [ __ ] so
going back to the economy side if the
right person's operating America we can
fix this unfortunately we have a hard
time with the current person that we got
because I don't even think he cares
about the economy I don't think he cares
about it I don't really care about the
economy he cares about the economy
understands the economy I don't think he
cares about security I don't think those
three things are priority to him I'm
being zero I don't and I don't how do
you say he doesn't care about I don't
think those three issues are in his top
five issues I don't think he puts puts
economy security Border in his top five
issues I'm not going to fight you on the
security in the Border because we can
obviously go down the rabbit hole here
if there's a U.S president that doesn't
have the economy in their top three I
don't care who it is left right up down
green purple they're [ __ ] missing the
boat but by the way you're right and he
is missing the boat I don't think he
cares about the economy because I mean I
have a hard time believing he doesn't do
hair George Will who hates Trump I agree
who hates Trump but Ultra conservative
but but Ultra conservative it's very
important for the fact that you said
that yeah so listen to yourself George
Will who can't stand Trump can't stand
the fact that Bill O'Reilly wrote a book
called killing Reagan and went after
Reagan cannot if you want to see a
shouting match go watch George Will Bill
O'Reilly but he cannot stand Trump at
all you know what he said yesterday
George Will begs if he can show this on
the screen so the viewers can see it
begs Democrats not to run Biden Harris
2024 and risk America to Trump in
scorching op-ed you know why because he
knows these two guys could care less
about the economy and maybe a top 10
issue it is not a top five issue for
them I think it's like one of those
things when you wake up in the morning
you're like yeah I gotta have some
breakfast I gotta have coffee that's in
your top five working out wow not in my
top five probably my top 20. I'm gonna
skip it today coffee top three you think
economy's top three and this guy's a
daily issues when he wakes up hell to
the no if it was he would have talked
about it yesterday it's not on his mind
to voters right now whatever you is
nothing he's pandering the voters he's
going to talk what he thinks people want
to hear in order to drive the base
that's the point we can't talk about the
economy right now because economy [ __ ]
but he doesn't realize so so if you and
I right now if you got a big ass cut
here your leg is broken like literally
you just broke your leg and I'm telling
you so what do you think about what
happened with the Lakers yesterday
Like Pat my leg is broken dude who cares
they won yesterday yeah it's freaking
awesome the Lakers want you to you're
like dude my leg is broken so America's
saying my economy is broken you're
talking about that elections are not
going to get the Real Results for for
three days what the hell are you talking
about no he has no clue
that's messaging no it's called it's
called lack of interest in the economy
it's not messaging Adam there's
something interesting economy you have
to go on the this is the way the left
views the economy
print or tax or regulate and the guy
who's on the far side of tax and
regulate that's Bernie Sanders I've now
described you what the far left looks
like Ultra regulate Ultra tax and then
over here print just print the stuff AOC
has even said we should do it says why
not print another 1.1 trillion if it
helped all the people then print another
they don't understand that there is a
piper to be paid and it is the Federal
Reserve balance sheet they on the left
they don't think okay by the way I fear
I hear what you're saying but Bernie
Sanders and Arc don't have anything to
do with the [ __ ] economy thank God
I'm talking about they're not doing
anything I agree they're not Paul
volcker they're not Janet Yellen they're
not Jerome that is the that's not the
people touching the economy Adam they
wish they could that's correct thank God
that's the number line of going to the
left of how they approach the economy
you tax it you print you regulate and go
take a look at what happened in Greece
10 years ago 10 take a look why there's
there's conservative leaders getting
elected in Europe because the people
know it doesn't work what's going on
here in Brazil is all connected if
you've heard about International economy
and they talk about brick bric Brazil
Russia India China as the four biggest
economies outside of what is known as
the Western Democratic economies
Australia Japan UK EU United States
Canada well guess what the b in Brick is
Brazil and the globalists do not want a
conservative right turning Brazil that
is what is happening here this is all
aligned on the globalist left-line
thinking it's it's all connected to me I
see a picture coming together very
rationally and that's why you've got
George Will stepping out like this going
saying for the good of the Republic
let's not go here and he does not sign
up to Maga or Trump or things like that
but he's saying let's not go here please
no so he's right so then Democrats have
rarely the last Democrat president that
cared about the economy as a top five on
his list was Clinton okay well that's
the last time that someone actually had
a good balance sheet but the last one is
closest to balancing the federal budget
he had he let's let's not downplay this
like he was all by himself without the
help of Newt Gingrich and he was a man
of the year Time Magazine 19. let's not
forget like what he did so everybody
typically says Clinton nobody gives a
credit to Newt Newt behind closers on
the show yeah because his name is new
correct who the hell wants to get your
name's new one the sharp he was a time
actually Man of the Year by a liberal
magazine named a far conservative right
man of the year and an Olympics the
economy so but but going here 12 years
the last time this happened the last
time it happened under the Democratic
president was a Bill Clinton Democrats
don't wake up in the morning with their
number one priority being you know uh
economy Biden said multiple times the
most important issue
today's climate change the most
important issue it's not gen it's not
economy they don't think economy you
think economy the average person thinks
economy they don't think economy they're
trying to Sidetrack you and confuse you
from where the economy is headed towards
but can I give just a little uh two a
little my two cents I I happen to think
I don't know if I'm right if I'm wrong
if if the economy is not in his top
three he's completely missing the boat
so I don't know what's in his brain half
[ __ ] he doesn't might not know he
doesn't know what's happening exactly
but if he's not meeting with his
economic team on the regular Janet
Yellen and the whole Squad I mean you're
missing the boat here but here's my
final point this is great we're having
this macro economic talk that's awesome
amazing there's things that you can
control as there are things that matter
so this matters but we can have we have
no control when I say we I don't mean
people with mouthpieces like we actually
do have a little bit of control I'm
talking about the average viewer out
there you know there's a famous saying
that don't fight the FED you've heard
this saying before don't fight the FED
meaning like there's nothing you could
do about the [ __ ] fed sorry not
gonna happen but what can you do so two
years ago it's crazy how things can
change like that davo Switzerland two
plus years ago Ray dalio you've
interviewed him he sat down and he gave
a whole big speech this is like a month
before covid and the famous thing was
what cash is trash cash is trash
two years later
180 what is he saying now well guys my
bad hey turns out cash is pretty good
yeah cashing trash cash is King okay so
what can you do about it there's nothing
you could do about higher credit card
rates there's nothing you could do about
higher mortgage rates there's nothing
you can do what do you mean you can but
you can
well hear me out and then you tell me I
want to hear what you okay I'm eating
whatever the FED fund rate is what a
3.75 to 4 yeah there's nothing you could
do about that what you can do if you're
listening and you're watching is
statcash
and when the when there's a right moment
and a right opportunity you can seize
the moment Carpe Diem however the
everything that the FED is doing unless
you're super super super creative and
that's why I want to hear your response
like you're not going to do anything to
you know quell how how high interest
rates are going there's nothing you
could do you stack cash you you maybe
you get a higher checking account you're
going you went from you went from one
subject to a completely different
subject okay so we were talking about
the economy being a priority and you're
saying how could you say the president's
priority is not economy it's not it's
not in his top five period what you're
saying is that the average person
watching us you can't do nothing about
it so you know tune out and just go do
your thing and try to stack something
I'm saying when it comes to your money
there's nothing you could do about
interest rates I was very clear you
can't fight the fed you can't change it
I think long term long term you can with
the way you vote you can with the way
you raise your kids to think about money
in a certain way you can with the way
people think of about fiscal
responsibilities you can with going back
to Common Sense you can with going back
to teaching math do you know what's the
one thing I judge parents on I look at a
parent the other day I sat down we play
a game with our kids here's what the
game is for every parent that wants to
get their kids to get better in math
just the game we play we're at lunch
here's how the game goes let's play
matter of fact all five of us gonna play
right now the four of you I'm gonna play
with you right now you ready audience
you can play this as well if you want to
we'll go with Adam to make it easy and
then we'll go you're going to be the
hardest one because it's out starts yeah
Adam one times one
one two times two four or three times
three Tom don't play games four times
four sixteen five times five twenty five
six times six thirty six seven times
seven forty nine eight times eight
sixty-four nine times nine eighty one
ten times ten eleven times eleven
hundred twenty one Thirty twelve times
twelve I don't know
okay 145 wow
how are you for the rest of your life
yeah okay 12 times 12 what's the easiest
way to figure out the answer is 144. you
take 12 times 10 which is what 100 120
okay then you take
2 times 12 which is what 24. 24 plus 24
plus 120 is what 24 plus 120 is 140 144.
you only have 13 times 13. [ __ ] me 166.
169. 14 times 14.
uh
uh 140
184 180. so you're right 140 then take 4
times 14 which is what
4 times 14 do 2 times 14 is 28 28 times
2 is what 56. what's 56 plus 140. 196 is
is okay what's the next one go you're at
uh 14 times 14. you did 14 times 15
times 15. 2 55 225 25 16 times 16. you
guys by the way the point can I say
something no so half the audience
is like dude that was sick Pat just like
broke it down I got it
I want to make a point to you you know
what happened yeah we're doing this
Sunday night my nephew was there Sean
okay great kiss Jennifer is sitting next
to me Mario sitting next to me here and
I'm not even talking to Jennifer and I'm
not even talking to Mario all of a
sudden they're kind of like
Pat how did you just come up with that
formula and Mario's like
holy [ __ ] I needed that in high school
literally that's all you do I said so so
we went all the way up to 30. oh my god
with nine-year-old kids I said let's do
29 times 29 what's 29 times 29. 2 times
29 is what 58. you add a zero which is
what 580.80 so now we have a 9 times 29
which is not easy but let's do what's 9
times 2. 18 you add a zero 180 okay so
so far we have what 180 plus 580 is what
760. so what do we have left
what do we have left
come on we have 9 times 29 we did nine
times twenty all we have left is nine
times nine which is what 81.81 what's 81
Plus 760.
841. and then you got this bro hello but
the point is we need to teach economy we
need to teach numbers we need to Value
math we need to Value Logic the more we
value voting through logic we're not
going to fall for this [ __ ] stuff
that they're talking about we're not
teaching enough people to learn how to
reason to learn how to make decisions to
learn formulas on what makes the economy
work everything in life for me is about
figuring out the formulas I watch you
you don't even know this I watch you and
I look at Adam when he walks if you look
at the way Adam walks Adam walks like
he's 22 years old okay but here's the
one thing most people don't know about
Adam every morning doesn't matter where
it is what do you do in the morning when
you wake up I stretch I do yoga how long
you stretch in the morning do I have a
pbd podcast that morning because like 30
seconds but no matter what if you don't
have a pbd podcast how long you
stretching a half hour but you do it
every day yeah okay guess what I'm in my
40s that's a formula you ought to wake
up in the morning and do stretch I'm
looking for 4 formulas I look at time
when I'm on the road with Tom it doesn't
matter what time it is at night you know
what's the last call Tom makes to his
kids how's your day today what'd you do
today how was school how was your test
how was your exam he does it with both
of his girls no matter how many places
we're in life I want to borrow great
formulas our job is to borrow great
formulas in every aspect of life we just
learned printing money is not a good
formula remember this the next time they
want to you know somebody's running to
say I want to print money talk things
out just remember certain formulas don't
work so yes short term go get your cash
go make your money because a lot of
shit's gonna be on sale next year but
long term get a little bit more clear on
your philosophies so you don't fall for
the same [ __ ] people keep voting for
and then they say I can't believe we're
in this economy you voted for this
person what do you mean you don't know
how you you voted for this person well I
just didn't like the other person next
time don't vote based on emotion or
identity vote a little bit more on logic
formula and ideas not purely emotion so
I think long term we need common says to
come back to be popular again we've
stepped away from that what we just did
right now some basic math formula that
we lost 90 of the audience I guarantee I
guarantee a lot of parents I guarantee
you how many guys that are parents that
you have kids under the age of 12 are
planning on doing this with your kids
this Sunday yeah comment if you would
and and basically what you're saying is
and I get it you know I get the media
attack Trump and went after them so
you're saying stop thinking about
personality and think about the policy
the stuff that these people are pitching
you know what I mean like that's what
Trump again same argument hate him
orange guy Demon World worth whatever
the policies were kicking ass and the
proof was in the pudding we went like
this and now the other side's excuses
well at least it ain't that guy which is
[ __ ] I I'd have more respect if
Biden if any president just came on goes
oh yeah listen
we're [ __ ] up all right give us a
little bit more time to try admit that
you're doing it because we all see it
they don't have the balls and be like
listen it's we we're screwing up bad but
my bad I don't know can I can I throw
I'd like to go to next topics but last
one here take us home here go for it
listen we all remember in 2010 when the
Tea Party came in to to effect during
the midterms those midterms so there was
like 12 years ago like this week and it
was an idea and a philosophy right and
essentially those are all political
conservatives right correct a lot of
those guys are more libertarian and bass
but I talked about what they were gonna
do quote unquote dude
I'm gonna do this I guess all I'm saying
is there's different
there's no doubt that Republicans
focus more on the economy if you're more
conservative you're more conservative
with your ideology but also with your
money you're more fiscal conservative
I'm with for sure the conservatives on
that side of the equation but I think we
would be doing kind of a disservice to
pretend that Trump didn't also print 2.2
trillion dollars of money when covet
started so like there's the Trump effect
but he also like he's with the person
that up like as far as covid goes he was
the person responsible for operation
warp speed he kind of got stuff going so
I like I hear what you're saying because
I do agree with you but I can't just
give Trump a free pass as if he like did
everything great and he didn't wasn't
responsible for
printing money and creating covered you
know vaccines and all that so it doesn't
exactly always equate that way yeah so
tell me why I'm wrong go ahead tell me
why tell you why you're wrong
this this guy shut down coming in from
China immediately they said this guy's
anti-aging racist they said he's racist
this guy tried to put you know uh uh
what do you call it on taxes when he was
putting tariffs on China and oh he is
racist this guy shut down anybody doing
business with Iran uh and flat output
tariffs and banned anybody doing
business with them oh he's right this
guy was ready to shut down Tick Tock and
oh no I can't believe he's going to be
doing this and we realized what Tick
Tock is doing right now with a story
this week just yesterday we were talking
about this on Tuesday Tick Tock is
potentially the next app to go down he
was the only guy that had the brass to
make tough decisions and the reality
during that time when Kobe came out
nobody had a clue what the hell was
going on with the pandemic they didn't
want to blame China everybody wanted to
blame covet on him he's in the middle of
a saying what the hell are we doing this
guy that's supposed to know everything
Anthony fauci is saying it's best if we
shut down if I don't I'm going to go
against science what do we do if I'm
shutting down restaurants I got to pay
the money [ __ ] if we tell telling you
can't go to work we have to pay for the
money you're not making then what we're
gonna do it was hands tied against his
back and it made him look horrible and
it's why he lost the election if Kobe
doesn't happen he's your president today
and we're not in the economy that we
have today matter of fact even yourself
covet doesn't happen he's president
today tell us where's the market out
today well did we print five trillion
dollars or no no we didn't if covet
doesn't happen if kovit doesn't happen
assuming that he wouldn't have printed
any money if Kobe doesn't happen you
don't need to print any money what do
you mean if kova didn't happen why do
you print any money oh you're saying if
kova just didn't happen there is no
question that [ __ ] didn't but but if
covet didn't happen who's your president
today it would likely be Trump and how
would the economy be today
hopefully better than it is now of
course but that's okay that's yeah well
it's a no-brainer listen just just to be
super clear what I'd rather have Trump
any good economy in 2022 or covet in a
bad economy I don't care how much you
hate Trump you [ __ ] take Trump in the
good economy nobody wanted the atom of
two years ago wouldn't have said that no
that's not true the atom of two years
you think I'm rooting for covid nobody
rooting for a bad economy no don't
change the answer don't get dramatic
here all I'm saying to you is if they
they needed something to get this guy
out because he was exposing all these
politicians and they hated it they
couldn't stand it the way he did it he
could have been 10 times smoother but he
was exposing all of them and they hated
it for it you can you can bash the guy
you can trash it you can say whatever
you want if somebody is targeted that
hardcore for this many years and
nothing's happened to him yet with
Russia all these scandals you are naive
if you believe 90 percent stuff is true
naive if you believe 90 90 of the stuff
they went after is true well you said
two things there if I can I know we want
to move on but
yes the media completely lied about him
and you know you what what came first
the you know the chicken or the egg did
he hate the media or they hated him and
he was attacking them so we are in full
on fundamental agreement there but you
also said something else were you
basically saying that kovid was
essentially created to get Trump out of
office no I never said that no but you
said that like I don't I don't even say
it they needed something that started
but but you're saying they needed
something to get him out it's not they
needed they they needed a crisis to get
them out right and they used covet as
the best crisis ever there could have
been a better crisis given handed over
to them I'm not saying that they didn't
create that though who the hell said
create tell me no I'm not rewind to see
where we said you're saying they needed
something no they were opportunistic
they saw this happen of course when 9 11
happened what did Bush do
he United America of course and and what
it what did the media in ninth in 2001
do they all got back we got behind each
other yes or no it was the biggest
tragedy in America since Pearl Harbor so
of course if you're an American you're
gonna have a little well this is a
pretty big tragedy with covet that took
place and this covert tragedy that
happened what did they do they blame
Trump instead of China yeah you can't
tell me you don't remember that and they
called him a racist 20 years ago but
when covet happened it was his fault
even though he should the moment he shut
down China Nancy Pelosi the next day was
in Chinatown yeah and as you change your
position two weeks later and we should
we should have closed China earlier what
the hell are you talking about the level
of the level of hypocrisy lost during
covet they lost their credibility they
used Russia it didn't work they tried to
use covet it worked they used a crisis
but what they got with the crisis they
used which is awesome you have no idea
how glad I am America got Biden I can't
even describe it to you I love the fact
that Biden's our president because of
one reason you know why because
everyone's seeing what the opposite
policies look like and people behind
closers are like oh my God this isn't
and I voted for this guy do you know how
many people have voters remorse right
now a lot of people I know a lot of
people that are voters remorse you know
what is the only reason people who have
voters remorse won't say publicly
because we hate being wrong our ego's in
a way there's no way we're going to
admit to Isle of Voters remorse voters
anymore they'll still go back anything
but that guy no people have voters
remorse tell me what's going on with
your job today tell me what's going on
with the economy today tell me what's
going on with your lifestyle today tell
me what's going on with your gas station
today tell me what's going on tell me
what you're thinking about I'm so glad
this happened for people to realize what
the opposite looks like the next time
around think twice when you vote
if the right votes are going to be going
through like what they're talking about
when Biden says it's going to take a lot
of places three four days do it for
decades for years without the current
technology that we have we had results
that same night four years you mean to
tell me technology is backtracking and
now you need more time to count what are
you talking about in every single thing
I'm getting data analytics faster we
just bought a technology six years ago
five years ago we invested 10 million
dollars into it I can pull up the data
right now while I'm talking to you I can
tell you exactly how many policies we
sold last night okay I can pull it up
right now while I'm talking to and many
times I do while I'm on the podcast I
check to see how her day was yesterday
okay I just go here one button boom I
can say exactly how many policies we
sold last night I can say exactly
you know 300 policies were submitted
last night I can see that with this you
mean to but but if you asked me this 12
years ago hey how many policies were
submitted last night I would have to
call on more hey let me check with the
Department we're going to get back to
you in a minute four hours later we sold
28 policies last night we didn't have
technology now you need three days to
decide elections and since 1776 with no
technology we had results the same now
93 additional days you're a you're a
qualified naive
there's many words I can add if you
actually believe that they need three
additional days if you're not skeptical
in that statement you get you deserve
exactly what you get if you're not
skeptical in that statement and Pat not
to be a conspiracy guy I'm just saying I
can have an opinion and I could have a
thought if 2020 was a movie and you
wrote a movie that was okay this this
figure is just you know crazy and he's
loud and this government wanted to get
them out and the the country that he put
all these tariffs and all this all this
trade stuff with all of a sudden a virus
comes out of this lab that we own that
now we're finding out leak they're
finally admitting it and made everybody
stay home and have to vote in by mail
and now this this guy that stayed in the
basement all of a sudden had the most
votes ever some people would be like
holy [ __ ] what a movie how's it end this
is how it's this is the ending of the
movement but but all of them said this
is all I'm saying this is all I'm saying
I'm not telling you there was voter
fraud we know there's voter fraud in
every election of course but but for a
person to say for a person to say that
hey you know we're going to end up
needing a few more days in 1700s in
1800s they got results same night we
have better technology smarter people
today you mean our system got worse you
have to be a [ __ ] to believe that or
you choose to believe it because you
like it because it favors you or if
you're a halfly logical reasonable
person who sits behind closed doors even
though you're sitting there saying I
don't like that guy I'm a true natural
Democrat you're behind closed doors
you're in the bathroom you're watching a
video and somebody says something like
that you have to say something like this
I don't know about that that sounds a
little strange that sounds a little why
do you why do we after all this
technology today if you're out there
you're listening to this and you're
saying Pat I disagree with you fine go
present this argument to people around
you tonight at the dinner table talk to
your friends talk to your family
for hundreds of years 200 whatever
you're 60 years to 1776 today we can do
the math for many years 240 something
years we've done okay with getting the
results of elections that same night in
different states
but now with all the technology that we
have that we can get any results you can
go on analytics on Instagram and find
out how many people shared your post you
can go on analytics on Twitter and find
out how much reach you got but you
cannot find the people that voted on the
same not to announce it on MSNBC Fox and
CNN okay wink wink you're right you're a
dummy if you fall for that period and
I'm not a dummy so that's the only level
of skepticism I have that when the
economy is where it's at and you're
talking about elections look folks you
know all I'm saying to you is keep your
eyes open there's been people how many
people have had family members that
stole from them how many people have had
family members that have stolen from
them everybody have you had family
members that have stolen from you have
you had family members that have stolen
from you have you had friends that have
stolen from you have you had a friend
that backstabbed you have you had a
girlfriend that stole from your backstab
from you if your own blood
will steal from you you don't think the
government will lie to you like who do
you think do you think you matter to
have these guys yeah no so we can't be
that naive and think it's not possible
we have to be a little bit more alert we
have to be a little bit more wary we
have to be a little bit more skeptical
we have to stay paranoid because that's
when you are able to protect yourself
very simple you know what sucks about
you saying this going to what we said
you can't we talk about the time you
can't even have an opinion like I don't
trust them you can't even talk about it
just just like with the Instagram can
you tell everybody what you notice so uh
somebody send this to me yesterday I'm
like there's no way for the past two
days time we've been you know posting
videos because I've been shooting
sketches and forever since I've been
with the company I've been tagging at
valuetainment on Instagram yeah you know
something you go and tag it yeah now if
you go to tag it it uh a warning comes
up and goes hey just letting you know
this ad uh has has done false
information this handle false false
information and false this do you still
want to tag them like they're
babysitting me because they're warning
me about valuetainment guys we're
sending me this yesterday I'm like
there's no way I didn't even bring it up
to anybody and then you brought it up
because this morning pre-podcast I
wanted to show my fans tested right now
I just did yeah hit me with it
what's it say what does it say it says
uh try to tag valuetainment guys let me
trust so what do you do you go and you
try to close your story I'm just
reposting what we talked about and I
type in value
information that was reviewed by
independent fact Checkers that went
against their Community guidelines do
you want to mention this account yeah
who's who's independent fact Checker
Tyler who is that
Mark Zuckerberg has admitted that the
the fact Checkers are just well by the
way bias basically by the way by the way
guess what fine do it you know what's
happening guess who this favors more
guess who this favors
guess who this favors
one company that's gonna blow up another
trillion dollar company keep playing
these [ __ ] games you're good I
tweeted at Elon yesterday saying tell me
how we can get in on the investment
yesterday Kathy Wood from Arc who hates
Elon Musk and shorted Tesla all of a
sudden got some money in it where you
can invest directly into Twitter and you
know you put you can do as low as 500 a
month but only 12 goes into Twitter so I
tweeted at Elon I got a group of people
that want to invest into Twitter how can
we get involved you know why I'm doing
that because I think that's going to be
a trillion dollar company I think and
it's I know I think I believe it's going
to be a trillion dollar company why
because I'm confident Facebook's gonna
screw up I'm confident tick tock's gonna
screw up I'm confident Instagram's gonna
screw up and I'm confident elon's Gonna
Keep It Freer than the rest and that's
why I believe Twitter is going to be a
trillion Auto Company
her politics are blue money is green I
called my financial guy yesterday told
him how much I want to put on Twitter
says you want to go that high said yes
says you sure I said yes wow yes I want
to go that right because not because of
just Elon because I know the other guys
are going to piss off too many people
what do you mean misinformation on
valuetainment you kidding me like we're
an entrepreneur site that's talking
about business and issues and finance
and economy and you're going to say
these guys post stuff like that we one
of your videos on Instagram got how many
views on on vitamins 29 million 29
million views you're ah whatever sound
they're cheating it's hilarious but
anyways it is what it is let's continue
with the next topic hopefully the next
one we won't need 55 minutes okay
I think that was good uh within that
topic I think we hit up like 10 other
topics okay nearly 40 nearly 40 of small
businesses in the US fail to pay rent in
October this is a Daily Mail story
the findings published Tuesday by
boston-based business tracker alignable
illustrate the Stark effect inflation is
having on everyday Americans the survey
of 4789 small business owners some more
than half of respondents say their rent
is at least 10 percent higher it was six
months ago interesting ten percent
higher than it was six months ago if you
go back even seven months the majority
said rents have increased 20 percent
this 20 20 so if you're paying 10 grand
a month now it's twelve thousand dollars
a month the study found that roughly 37
percent of small business owners almost
half of all Americans working in private
sector were left unable to pay rent in
October compounding concerns is the fact
that several states such as New York and
California are already well over already
we're well over the already high
national average uh Tom what are your
thoughts when you see a number like this
how important is this to the average
person this is hugely important because
this is the dry cleaner down the street
that you go to this is the little
butcher shop in Brooklyn and that you go
to this is the small businesses you go
to this is the the bead and Art Shop
that your daughter goes to and gets
those little things for crafts after
school these are small businesses
sitting there on Main Street America
that are now this is the plumber that
you've used for 20 years and now his
little his little shop where he Parks
his trucks and his guys come in and he's
got a few sinks on display and stuff his
rent is up what this is saying is this
is real and so these these folks are
going what are they gonna have to do
they're going to have to raise prices a
little bit on you that's inflation to
the average person you say wow this is
terrible no this is the front end of
inflation the rent goes up so they have
to raise the price that you pay it's the
front end of inflation and this is to me
the the real fire in the mouth of the
Dragon hasn't been seen and we're going
to see it right here as we go into the
end of the year I mean this is the fire
in the mouth the dragon is it what I
mean
I I just can't say it any any more clear
it's why is the dragon have so much
stuff in his mouth what do you mean like
the the fire in the mouth of the Dragon
well I mean things are getting hotter
you've got now people these are
businesses are about to close these are
people that have a risk of going out of
business this isn't just a little
increase in the unemployment rate this
is these are small businesses that's
that are building the jobs or the core
of the economy and I'm saying that the
dragon breathing fires inflation and
this is a leading indicator got it
that's the key that's the word I was
looking for for leading indicator check
this out can you pull up Airbnb
what happened with their quarterly
earnings just type in Airbnb quarterly
earnings okay
and their numbers I think just came out
two or three days ago go to news go to
news at the top
go to yeah there you go go to news zoom
in a little bit
zoom in a little bit so we can there you
go click on that right there boom click
on the first one CNBC
uh Airbnb earnings ninety percent
it's okay I don't want them 90 their
traffic is coming to the pro no go to
the top one that's the one I want yeah
so look at this shares of Airbnb tumble
13 on low fourth quarter guidance okay
go zoom in a little bit more so we can
read that uh for the fourth quarter
Airbnb set it expects to deliver between
1.8 billion to 1.88 billion below the
midpoint of 1.85 as expected by an
analyst go a little lower
so why this Airbnb data matter okay
Airbnb beat on tolerance of the company
posted a revenue of 2.9 billion Tony
ever somebody get over here it's only
2.8 billion percentage but Airbnb
provided fourth quarter Revenue guidance
at 1.8 1.85 everyone is expected to a
continued uh Albright choppy recovery of
cross-border travel to be further
Tailwind to Future results as count
countries around the world continue to
recover from covert lockdowns and
grapple with high level inflation rates
Airbnb also cautioned that the strong
dollar will lower its International
average daily rate analysts at evercore
isi said that this was the key negative
in the opponent of silicone all in we
have fundamental Trend we're resilient
okay so if people are if airbnb's
numbers are 13 lower to Tumble their
stock tumbles because they're thinking
traffic's not going to be as high why
are people not traveling as much why are
people not spending that money that's
another indicator you have to be careful
with that people are not spending that
money there are certain areas exotic
cars down collectible cards down nfts
down nearly 94
you can go through so many of these
things that people just kind of throwing
money at it yeah you want to go on a
vacation let's go get an Airbnb yeah you
want to go let's go buy a collectible
card the same Kobe Bryant card that's
one of two that sold for 1.7 million
dollars
two years ago I want to say sold for 690
000 two months ago
okay there's only two of those cards
it's his best card in the world only
sold for six six ninety roughly 700 000
this card got a 1.7 million dollars a
year and a half ago in the last 12 18
months same exact card same you know how
we say VIN number same exact
identification everything's the same
so for more than 50 why
why are people not doing it I don't know
maybe people are hoping they keep their
cash because they're going to need it
for other places so when you're seeing
businesses not paying rent forty percent
of our behind that's problematic you
need those guys to be paying their rent
so Twitter let's go to Twitter and some
Elon Musk stories here
Twitter employee okay first of all let's
talk about uh okay
um Twitter asked uh uh Elon Musk owl's
Twitter board named Soul director and
people are overreacting to this oh my
God God forbid for this guy to do
something like this Twitter said in the
Securities filing Monday that the nine
members of its board uh a former board
are no longer directors of the
consummation of 44 billion dollar merger
musk always intended to take over as a
sole director under the terms of the
merger agreement according to the filing
the dissolution of the board was this
slow disclosed in a broader Securities
filing that spelled out other
formalities as part of the deal closing
including repayment okay great so the
market reacts oh my God he fired
everybody on the board he's the sole
director this is bad news I just sold my
insurance company uh June 27th and we
had a good sized board and when we
talked to the company that's buying it
they didn't buy 10 of it they didn't buy
20 of it they bought a hundred percent
the company
when we talk to them there's no longer
the board I'm a managing director and
the board members are nicely kindly
asked hey thank you for your service
thank you for what you did but you're no
longer board member the new owner
chooses to not have that board because
that's how things like this happen but
this makes for a great headline this
makes for a great story and he's the
sole director because he owns Twitter
that's what the normal person that buys
a company does he gets to choose that he
didn't get rid of them for any reasons
he didn't fire them it's just what you
do when you buy a company Tom want to
hear a story like this what do you think
about it oh it's just piling there
everybody's piling on Elon Musk they're
just piling on trying to find a story
where there's nothing Burger there if
someday he takes Twitter public again he
will have a board of about nine people
why because the law says that under
Securities in Exchange Commission says
that you need to have a board and
compensation committees and audit
committees and things like this but when
let's put it this way if you're out
there thinking about this and you own a
small business who's the owner you who's
your board yourself who are your
advisors maybe your spouse maybe friends
maybe family maybe Patrick David is your
one of your advisors it's just you but
if you went public the law says you have
to have a board Twitter is no longer
public and I look at this and it's just
like what Pat just said about selling
his company this is piling on this is a
nothing Burger these are people saying
oh my gosh he oust his board he didn't
oust this board they were a public
company board and when the public
company dissolves you no longer need a
very normal thing it's not it's not a
big thing it's not just normal it's
according to the legal regulations of
how you organize and tax a company but
it makes for a great headline a matter
of fact this next one's even better if
you want to hold this what you say
they're good there he goes again it lets
you and CNN will say there he goes again
can you pull up Elon Musk Q score I'd
like what I want to know is
like what is it about Elon or why
there's so much hate towards Elon is it
because he's a billionaire because he
trolls people is it because he's
childish it's because they the word he's
taking over the world he's is he is he
an advocate of free speech because you
know that's not what they like these
days apparently I don't know I think
freedom of speeches
he's an entrepreneur who won't toe the
line and is unafraid of you that's no no
no but why do people I understand if why
maybe like big government wouldn't like
him or even big Tech or you know
competitors I'm saying average people
what is it about Elon that pisses people
off you see all these famous people even
Twitter go to Gates
okay so go to Elan
okay go to Cuban
go to Buffett
go to Bezos
elon's the most dis Bezos is the most
disliked by the way out of all of them
interesting Bezos is 38 yeah can you go
over these numbers yeah if you if you
look at uh go to Donald Trump Jr let's
see what that one says he's disliked by
53 go to Zuck of course he's disliked by
49 almost Zuck is almost disliked as
much as Donald Trump Jr is that is very
very strange go up
so Bezos was what disliked by 38 Buffett
was 17 20
uh musk was 30 click on musk 33 and
Bates Gates was 29 if you click on Gates
by the way this uh numerical like order
is it like there's a there's a reason
for it is it based on Fame is that the
highest how they're putting this no I
think it's ranked on popularity well
yeah Fame popularity uh so Bill Gates is
97 then Elon keep going just boom boom
boom boom junior junior 93 80.
tell me tell me what's your question
so what I'm saying is yeah okay so we're
using what number are you looking at
what number are you focusing on the fame
the popularity they're just likely
looking at dislike okay you're looking
at this point you're saying you you said
why do so many people dislike them so
that's the number so okay gotcha so Bill
Gates is 29 Elon go quick Tyler so we
don't take a lot of people just did it
Elon is 33 Mark Cuban 17 Buffett is 20
uh Bezos is uh 38 Juniors 53 and Zuck is
49. yeah not sure why Junior's on that
list however very weird that I have
Junior on that list so if you had Donald
Trump on there even close to that so how
do you process this yeah that's what I'm
wondering is that uh
Zuckerberg and Bezos are way more hated
than Musk way more hated based on these
numbers yeah yeah interesting he's but
but here's the point it's such I'm so
glad you went here because great Point
you're making to say just because
politicians and mainstream media scream
at as loud as they are about how much
they dislike this guy the average person
actually likes this guy that's my whole
[ __ ] point you're right I'm like
what's with the hate on Eli you cannot
be again the one thing that we have to
work on as we mature in business like I
was a naive businessman
I was a naive salesperson I was a naive
player in the market you know you're not
naive when it comes down to girls
there's no way you're going to be naive
when it comes on or leave my personal
life but but what I'm saying is in we
all have areas of Our Lives where we're
not naive in where you don't fall for
[ __ ] okay for example yesterday
Dylan and I were driving the car said
Dylan who do you think is going to win
the Super Bowl oh that for sure the
Eagles so tell me why the Eagles oh Dad
are you kidding me they're I'm telling
you for sure they're winning I said what
are you talking I said dad they're 7-0
maybe the Giants maybe this maybe
Minnesota but it's going to be Eagles
win the championship so that's what you
call a naive fan and then I said look in
the game of sports winning the
championship has to do with what who is
the healthiest when playoffs start it
was the hottest team in during the
playoffs hottest and healthiest wins the
Super Bowl right most likely to win hot
and healthy whatever it comes down to
stuff like this you can't be naive and
say why does the media not like this guy
dude the media had a full-on monopoly on
controlling point of contact in the
narrative until this guy bought Twitter
Facebook actually has to now wake up and
say listen guy if you keep doing this
stuff of be careful because of a
disinformation stuff this guy's gonna
hurt you you know what he's trying to do
do you know what one of the things he's
trying to do can you pull up that Fox
Business article that Mario sent to us
yesterday it's a fantastic article uh
that Mario's very big on news and Wall
Street but like about the five things
that Elon wants to Elon musk's five
major moves in the first week of Twitter
ownership go up let's look at the five
go up okay number one dissolving Twitter
board okay that's done he owned 100 of
it go to two two is a firing top
executive zoom in zoom in zoom in some
people are very upset about what this
guy's doing here following the closing
of his acquisition musk fired agrawal
Chief Financial Officer Ned ziegel uh
Vijay Gadi Twitter's head of legal
policy trust general counsel Sean
edgette also confirmed on Twitter that
he is no longer with the company after
several hours reported he was including
this he says Thursday concluded five
years of Twitter I'm grateful for the
opportunity I've worked with such an
incredible group of people
okay great so now go to the next one go
to the next one point number three point
number three on what he did uh right
there bring bring in and look at this
one this is important bringing in Tesla
Engineers to review Twitter's code
and you better believe Tesla Engineers
running a trillion dollar company they
kind of know what they're doing of
course go to number four go to number
four launching content moderation
Council moderation Council and revamping
Twitter verification this is the Eight
dollar a month thing that he told uh EOS
if you go a little bit higher
uh right I'm sorry I say higher I mean
Lord yeah there you go uh Twitter will
not be an orange of the platform Twitter
will not allow anyone who was the
platform for violating Twitter rules
back on the platform until we have a
clear process for doing so which means
if some of you guys are wondering about
Trump it's not going to be happening
which will be for at least a few weeks
Twitter content moderation Council will
include Representatives with widely
Divergent views which will certainly
include the Civil Rights community and
groups who face hate field violence go
lower and show the last one which is
number five and I'll tell you what he
just tweeted the other day go to number
five Vine Revival which he wants to
bring Vine back and five million people
voted for that
seventy percent want that thing to come
back here's the point Iran said the
other day which is powerful and it's
important Vinnie to you and to Adam and
to Tyler here's what he's doing
he wants to pay content creators that's
great what does it mean he wants to pay
content creators what other platform
Pace content creators hello YouTube Pace
content creators Facebook Pace content
let me tell you this way if this guy
starts paying content creators on
Twitter and they start making money they
have to realize he is now officially the
most hated man both in politics and in
Silicon Valley because Silicon Valley
has controlled everybody because they've
had Facebook Twitter everyone and now
this guy picked them up and then in
politics they've had to control the
narrative now they can't call this guy
and say Hey you gotta de-platform that
guy hey you got to do this you gotta
nope cause he ain't playing by your
rules anymore that's why he's the most
hated guy by politicians and silicone
and want to talk about another people
that hate them uh Tyler if you pick it
up Christians and conspiracy theories
did you see where he wore for Halloween
the costume yeah the chess piece was a
the Baphomet like the Devil with the
upside down cross could you go to his uh
go to go to the look at the chess piece
zoom in on that Christians and everybody
are flipping out because this is the
devil's
um what's it called the devil's armor or
something like that go can you zoom into
the chest Tyler it's the upside down
Christians were not happy he has an
upside down cross and like the goat the
devil people are like he's a devil I
mean that's Halloween I mean I mean
Halloween but bro that's like that's a
eight thousand dollar costume the girl I
hung out with on Halloween she wore
Devil's outfit so it's like good for you
she was hot she's hot but for him to do
that but he pissed off a lot of people
you know I get that I'll tell you
ultimately I'm a I like Elon okay I'm
not like Elon guy he's the best I'm like
no I like Elon I think he's a necessary
guy I think he's an awesome guy
but to use your sports analogy with
Dylan and who's going to win the Super
Bowl I'm a sports guy you're a sports
guy World Sports guys anytime a new
coach or a new GM comes to a team Lakers
new coaches here we're cleaning the
house we're starting fresh yeah I want
my guys in there I want my offensive
coordinator I want my defensive guy I
want my guys in there bing bing bing
it's so par for the course no one talks
about it but when a guy comes into a
business and cleans house it's like oh
my God what's he doing that's
essentially what you're saying is like
this is normal stuff and I love I so
love and appreciate how real you get and
you reveal exactly what happened with
your company that you sold you're like
yeah I just did this the board that I
had everyone on the board they're no
longer there because I don't know not
because they don't like that because
it's a different question so it just
that's just let me make this very
they're very happy board
very yeah because they were not only
board members they were investors yeah
we we like that because that way you
want to help so anyway so there you have
it by the way pull up the picture with
the employee I'm so you know deeply
concerned about this picture that was
prop you know and somebody somehow took
the picture with a perfect angle Vinnie
you got to post the same picture today
on Instagram you got to put it up there
and say man by Taemin making me sleep
watch this here can you do you have it
or no you should have it somewhere here
I'll read the story while you're doing
this so Twitter employee seen sleeping
on office floor as Elon Musk pushes
tight deadlines
oh that looks like that looks like a
setup obviously nobody took that picture
at all no uh Twitter's director of
product management Esther Crawford was
photographed wrapped up in a sleeping
bag wedged between a table and some
chairs and would look like a conference
room with a sleep mask pulled over her
eyes Under the fluorescent lights of the
office when you need something from your
boss at Elon Twitter Evan Jones a
product manager Twitter spaces said in a
tweet Wednesday Crawford retweeted the
photo with the caption when your team is
pushing Round the Clock to make
deadlines sometimes you sleep where you
work inside obtained an internal message
telling workers the exception the
expectation is literally to work 24 7 to
meet musk's deadline for an overhaul of
Twitter user verification process okay
so let's play both cards let's say this
is true let's say this isn't true
obviously if it isn't true guess what
she got a lot of eyeballs if it isn't
true but let's play the card if this is
true Tom have you ever slept at an
office or a job that you had have you
ever done it yeah so many people know I
worked in Silicon Valley and there were
three times that I worked 24 hours
straight not a not a 18-hour day but 24
hours straight I worked I had a product
that was launching I was into it I was
excited I was also young I didn't have
kids but I was I was all over it and
yeah was the what did I have a a boss
that was just you know pushing all of us
really really hard and said no we were
pushing each other very hard and if you
take a look at what's here we were
pushing to an objective which was a
product launch I worked 24 hours I knew
people at other companies did it was
like a badge of honor nobody we didn't
feel that we were like some some
horrible horribly treated group of folks
we had stock options we had upside we
had things that we were working for and
we were passionate about it and guess
what people that didn't want to do that
they left and they worked elsewhere and
you know what I saw in this what are
these people doing
what has he got them working on an
overhaul of the verification process you
see that do you think that's important
right now to have credibility for
Twitter do you think it's important he
came in and said hey if you're in we
need to overhaul the verification
process and it needs to be 24 7 to get
this important Milestone done so that
people will trust and believe more in
our product that we're going out this is
not like a new normal for the next 10
years at Twitter and I think this is
another nothing Burger we're trying to
make him sound like he's some curmudgeon
that he's putting such pressure on
people no if you're into it and you're
sold in and you are all about it you do
it and I've I did it three separate
times by the way 24 hours and it's a
badge of honor I was passionate it was
exciting and these people are working on
yeah an important overhaul cool awesome
uh uh you know what's crazy is with CNN
CNN forgets why their company is still
around okay I dare you to go watch CNN's
documentary how they made it go watch
the videos at the beginning when they
were first doing 24 7 dues and that
Turner came out go see what buildings
they worked in go see how many nights
Ted Turner slept in the office go he
eventually slept on the floor above
where everybody was working he just
slept in the building people were there
24 7 to make CNN work the CNN employees
of today should be so grateful for the
people at the beginning stages of CNN
that slept in the office that sacrificed
that gave their lives away so you can
now make 10 20 million and some of the
guys can make two three four hundred
thousand dollars as Executives and CNN
is what it is today at least what it
used to be a few years ago because right
now the ratings came out yesterday and
it's terrible I feel bad for CNN that
they're going through this challenging
times hopefully the new guy is going to
fire the right people and bring the
right people and change that around but
the point is this
there is no company
that is massive today no Society no no
country that at one point the original
founders of that country of that Society
of that company
had sleepless nights
and did stuff that made no sense in
regards to work to get it to where it's
at today there isn't any you tell me
stories of actors you guys want to go
after Twitter why don't you go talk to
actors how many of them work 20 hour
shifts and yes Sac has to pay them the
overtime how many actors you know so how
was it working dude I just have to sit
there and they just call me man I could
be at any time I can do this and we got
to be up one time we did this 24 hours
one time we did that 18 hours
go talk about military you know how many
nights we would sleep like how many
times oh during 9 11 I was sleeping on a
rock a rucksack was my 36 hours one time
we did I'm like you seriously yeah we
have to do this you got to get used to
because if you can't do this how are you
gonna handle in war yeah in every
example can be given people that did
this but when you post something like
this and people overreact now guess what
this guy's a tyrant what a horrible Guy
this is now they're trying to make an
adjustment right now it's not going to
be like this forever it's at the
transitional stages that's going to be a
little bit annoying until the machine is
up and running based on the new systems
then it goes back to Business as Usual
by the way just to give some context you
don't hear these stories that's
currently going on at Tesla or at neural
link or at SpaceX you don't hear any of
these stories it's only at Twitter on
the one week he buys Twitter what do you
expect yeah okay how many times you
think they took that picture of that
girl well she like took off her things
she's like nope make sure the angle and
then she put on her little sleep mask
come on by the way I think this is 60
true I actually think it's it's a true
that she posted this uh but also at the
same time I think if you've never been
in a startup and let me make a
recommendation to folks if you don't
like stuff like this never work for
startup correct don't do it ever go work
for an established company don't ever
work for a startup company now for some
of you guys that have Workforce startup
and it made it I am sure you have a lot
of awesome stories I am sure you have
stories that you want to tell the world
about it how great it was there's
something very unique about being part
of a startup uh it's a very very unique
experience when you work for startups
okay let's talk about it there's also
one other thing that people should under
that there's a difference out there
between having a job and having a career
if it's just a job whatever it is if
it's just your job your give a [ __ ]
level will not be as high so there's
something called this is not a
scientific term Tom but it's a give a
[ __ ] level do you how much do you care
about what you're doing or not right so
if you have a question for your passion
or paycheck exactly if you have a career
that you're
you're passionate about that you you're
willing to sleep in the office and
you're willing to sacrifice that's how
you'll make it if it's just a job for a
paycheck of course you're not sleeping
at the office so you know whoever's
listening right now you know whether you
just have a job or you actually have a
career and it'll reflect in whether
you're sleeping at the office or willing
to bust your butt or make sacrifices or
not awesome let's go to the next story
that was great uh commentary there white
White House
shamed into deleting Social Security
boast after Twitter fact checked uh the
Biden Administration was forced to
delete a Twitter post taking credit for
Boost and retired Social Security checks
Wednesday after social media users
pointed out the increase was tied to
decades High inflation seniors are
getting the biggest decrease in Social
Security can you post this up so we can
see this how embarrassing is it when the
White House has to delete something uh
in Social Security checks in 10 years
though President Biden leadership let me
read this again seniors are getting the
biggest increase in their Social
Security checks in 10 years through
President Biden's leadership read the
tweet from the official White House
account Tuesday afternoon Twitter opened
the note to that claim that said readers
added context they thought people might
want to know seniors will receive a
large social security benefit increase
due to annual cost of living adjustment
which is based on the inflation rate
note said linking to Social Security
Administration website for an
explanation on the Nixon era legislation
behind this increase please okay for all
of those who thinks that I'm just a
biting apologist like listen clearly
nice try there sleepy Joe and I just
freaking dry here buddy I saw this I was
like come on buddy but doesn't it feel
good that they're getting checked no
just like seniors are getting the
biggest increase in their social
security in 10 years thanks to Joe Biden
President Joe Biden's leadership and
this is nobody nobody it's because
inflation is [ __ ] north of eight
percent yeah and this is by law what
needs to happen so seniors who are
living on fixed income right can live
because Joe Biden doesn't want old
people dying in their homes in the
headlines so of course you need to do
this protect people people need money to
pay the bills but of course they need
money to pay the gas every the grocery
everything we get it nice try Joe nice
try Karine St Pierre John Pierre but it
wasn't the economy down go ahead
but doesn't it feel good that it's fine
only happening to the other side because
if you think about it they're every
Trump trump was getting checked fact
check every two seconds now that they're
getting checked can you imagine all the
[ __ ] that they've done in the past two
years that nothing's happened but
there's a difference between fact check
and deleting
especially from the white house because
here's what you think about one who the
hell tweeted that who approved it who
checked it what is the pro you're the
White House if you need this much
verification to have a tweet go out how
the hell are you gonna run the world how
the hell are you going to run the
country if you can't handle one simple
account of Twitter can't you have five
people that check something before they
send all it takes is one person to say
well president before we tweet this out
this is not because of you yeah this is
because of the structured setup no no no
just put it out there we're gonna need
it for the midterms it's going to show
us we're doing a good thing but bad
thing about like now this is two years
later like uh he finally got has Twitter
how much [ __ ] are they tweeted that was
a lie in these past
there's nothing you can do about it
there's nothing you can do about it so
pop Pelosi attack uh uh cops weren't
monitoring cameras during break-in uh uh
I'm you know I'm sure you saw this story
we talked about I think briefly on
Tuesday but uh the Capitol Police has
live cameras outside Democratic house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi's home but officers
were reportedly not watching the feeds
when her husband was brutally assaulted
the Capitol Police first installed
cameras around the Pelosi residents more
than eight years ago the house speakers
24 7 security detail left San Francisco
with her when she returned to DC last
week and the Capitol Police Stopped
continuously monitoring the feeds
outside our house according to the
report police say David de beppe 42
years old broke into the house and
shouted where's Nancy he then allegedly
attacked her husband with a hammer
fracture in the skull go ahead Vinnie so
okay here's my thing and Tom we talked
about this before we went on air why is
it that we can't ask questions I can't
ask question like you just even little
bitty ones one like give me one like if
you were curious about this time what
would you like because you heard a bunch
of different stories what would be one
of your one of your questions gosh after
the last three years with the riots and
BLM I thought all cops had had body
cameras they have hold on that's a 100
guarantee after 30 seconds it comes on
and checks
I just said don't and it wasn't
California one of the leading states
that all cops have their body cameras
100 here's another great question oh
you're a conspiracy theorist you're
you're already conspiracy and here's the
thing you want to shut everybody up and
shut every cons every question asking
person release the camera on the cop so
we could see exactly what happened don't
leave it up the question because when
you leave it up the question then you
have people going wait a minute he was
in his underwear the other guy was in
his underwear the glass was broken From
the Inside Out the 9-1-1 call you
clearly hear the cops saying he says
it's his friend and his name is David
okay and then when he's screaming
where's Nancy I mean they could be a
bunch of different things and then
automatically they're going to put it
into January 6 and it was January 6.
there's just too many questions and I
feel bad for them and I hope he recovers
but then just a couple months ago when
he got a DUI boy he's been partying
party bro I think he's partying Pat and
to me this is my opinion yeah he
finished his community service and was
he in his recovery did he go to his
record I remember he had community
service and Recovery classes yeah I
don't know if he's finished that takes
that takes no I'm gonna be a reporter
and I'm going to take away conspiracy
hey wait a minute was her alcohol
involved wasn't he going to recovery
class possession community service
because the DUI 100 you're a conspiracy
theory conspiracy theories so I listen
there's just too many questions and
going back to it it's a good point
though have the cops show them can we
ask questions I mean how do you not have
the camera on the third most you know
powerful person in America I will tell
you one person who is trending is uh
since since he used the the hammer MC
Hammer song
has been doing very well
you mean to tell me Nancy Pelosi's house
doesn't have top-notch security and the
Father the husband is there she's not
there that's fine you cannot tell me
that because she's number two if God
forbid Biden dies and uh Kamala dies and
they both die in an accident Pelosi is
next in line she's number two not number
three you don't have cameras there I
don't believe it people are not dumb
people yeah I'm not I'm definitely not
done with that by the way of the 10
things going on in the world this is not
in my top 10 stories that I'm following
me me me okay same here I spoke let me
give a shout out to my buddy he's gonna
hear his name he's gonna flip out yeah
he's the biggest Mega supporter one of
my best friends Joey B if you're
listening we spoke for a half hour last
night he's like I gotta tell you I want
my my conspiracy everything I'm thinking
about Paul Pelosi I'm like all right
buddy entertain me for a half hour
so he's like so I think he knew the guy
I think he let him in I'm like okay all
right that's not far-fetched security
how did he get in of course how does how
does Nancy Pelosi sounds out of security
like I'm with you okay so he's like yeah
all this is going on so I'm like what's
your conclusion they're gay lovers I'm
like no no no no what where where does
that come from they're in their
underwear I'm like are you the doctor
he was sleeping at 2 A.M and the guy got
in the house somehow so like you're
entitled a hundred percent in America to
what you think but you can't say things
that you know like as if they're facts
what you think I'm like so I'm with them
I'm like oh yeah
how do you get in there it's crazy maybe
he let him in I don't know maybe he knew
him he was a friend I don't know he's
like they claimed that he was a Maga guy
but he's a BLM guy because he how many
Maga guys are in San Francisco living in
a [ __ ] calm you know not all right
cool no cool so The Logical conclusion
is they've been lovers all this time
it's like where did that come from I'm
not gonna lie
I messaged Pat and IG I took him a bunch
of Clips I was like Pat I even said it
they're both in their underwear he
didn't hit him until the cops showed up
and he's going where's Nancy that sounds
like a lover's quarrel yeah and he's
like where is that [ __ ] that sounds
like what I I said that's my guy Joey
one question I go the guy's 80 something
years old find me one other story he's
been in the public eye for 50 years one
other gay lover story he's like there
there's nothing out there I'm like
really so this is what's happening I
mean he's kept it for a long time right
one week before midterms yeah Nancy's
out of town boom now's my chance come on
bro yeah okay let's go to the next story
we're down let's go nonsense looks like
you guys got that out of your system
next story job openings rise
unexpectedly job openings rise
unexpectedly to 10.7 million in
September despite fed hikes uh despite
fed hike so let's look at this here your
shop owners Rose unexpected only
September suggesting that the American
labor market is not cooling as fast as
inflation Fighters at Federal Reserve
hoped employers post a 10.7 million job
vacancies in September up from an
upwardly of 10.3 million jobs in August
the labor department said Tuesday
economists had expected the number of
job openings to drop below 10 million
for the first time since June of 2021
another sign that the labor market
remains tight and employers are
unwilling to let workers go layoffs
dropped in September to 1.3 million the
fewest since April but the number of
people quitting their jobs slipped in
September to just below 4.1 million
still high by historical historical
standard uh Tom what does this mean to
us well I got up way too early had way
too much coffee and I saw that and I'm
like wait a minute what's behind the
numbers what's in this 10.7 so I went to
the United States Bureau of Labor
Statistics and I printed out the report
that was there and I said there's a
handy report here with column headings
and everything and I said first of all
where are these jobs and I just thought
it was kind of interesting uh the 10.7
million jobs 4.2 million of them are
open in the south
5 million is the Midwest and West and
there's only 1.7 million open in the
Northeast and that's actually down so
behind the 10.7 there are jobs open in
the south
level in the west and Midwest then down
in the Northeast okay that's very
interesting so they're following the sun
toward the winter but where are these
jobs well I saw a couple headlines this
week Apple freezes hiring I think we all
saw that nothing to see here they're
just saying hey we're on a hiring freeze
we've also seen a couple other tech
companies Silicon Valley and large
companies saying hiring freezes now
those are skilled workers white-collar
workers and also I found
um a couple little bit things on Venture
funded companies like uh one that stuck
out was gem which is Zen source which is
uh has 170 million dollars of venture
investment they just laid off one third
of their Workforce and they are a white
collar competitor to zip recruiter and
others well that's interesting so then I
said huh
I delve into the numbers check this out
of the 10.7 million 1.6 million of those
jobs are in Leisure and Hospitality in
other words restaurants hotels Food
Service
2.1 million are in social assistance
Health Care you know what that is that's
retirement community nursing hospice
things like that
so wow then
I said well how many are white collar
workers only 1.9 million so of the 10.7
only 1.9 million are white collar or
skilled work
so that lines up with apple saying well
we're freezing and then another one
stuck out this one's up
um to almost 1.7 from 1.5 over two
months
where wholesale transportation and
warehousing is up now why would that be
because we're going in the fourth
quarter baby and those are Amazon jobs
oh wow and those are in the new Dropship
economy we've got it's not just Amazon
it's up there so it was very interesting
to me and the government still had a
million of them out there so there's a
million jobs for the government so
what's really interesting to me is
there's two sides to this you've got
Hospitality
warehousing and retirement homes and
retirement communities accounting for
almost six million of the jobs and you
only have two million White Collar this
is called a barbell where you have two
ends of the barbell you know what I mean
and it's skinny in the middle so the
jobs that are being created are not high
paying high skill jobs that's what's
behind these numbers by the way so let
me tell you they like to talk about 10.7
because it's an election yeah but but
here's the problem though
here's the problem though so look look
at the way the article reads the article
reads and says the following it says uh
what page
so look but look listen to the way the
article reads New York says U.S job
openings Rose unexpectedly in September
suggesting that the American labor
market is not cool and as fast as the
inflation Fighters at Federal Reserve
hoped one more time uh suggesting the
American labor market is not cooling
meaning the Federal Reserve wants the
American labor market to cool off
so if this number is true guess what it
means for December what interest rate
with rate hikes you're going to get
another three quarters of a basis point
because it's not cool enough as weird as
this sounds this needs to cool off more
for them to get to only half or a
quarter but if you're getting numbers
like this Powell's sitting there saying
nope it's not working yet maybe one more
month maybe one more month so I'm I'm
leaning towards three quarters of a
basis point in December uh half to three
quarters of a basis point I don't think
it's going to go to a quarter he said
they're going to do half I think maybe
three quarters of basis point if these
numbers are not turning I'm with you 100
and I take this back to our uh economic
discussion on mortgages there are not
high paying jobs out there to go be able
to pay that higher percent mortgage
folks and so I said if your job is
moving you to another city under consume
your housing conserve your spending the
way you can and get through what is
going to be a two-year nuclear winter in
our economy an AKA save that money yeah
no question about AP News officials
Saudi tells U.S that Iran May attack the
kingdom Saudi Arabia had shared has
shared intelligence with American
officials that suggests Iran could be
preparing for an imminent attack on the
kingdom three U.S officials said Tuesday
the heightened concerns about a
potential attack on Saudi Arabia come as
the Biden Administration is criticizing
Tehran for its Crackdown on widespread
protests and condemning it for sending
hundreds of drones as well as technical
support to Russia for use in its war in
Ukraine the U.S and Saudis blamed Iran
in 2019 and being behind a major attack
in eastern Saudi Arabia which helped the
oil Rich Kingdom production and cause
energy price to spike so this this leak
of information from Saudis to U.S who's
who's uh who's does it seem like Saudis
are concerned that this could backfire
on them what's the motive behind this
dumb how do you process this I I process
it that you know if you're a bullying on
the playground sometimes you say he hit
me first and I I wonder if this is kind
of a little false flag that the Saudis
are putting up and the Saudis but if you
want to look up the Q rating for the
Saudis
probably probably just like it's gonna
be hired in irondo
for sure but you know what's interesting
they were only 99 hated by the news
media so I want to know the one guy that
that uh that wouldn't vote on that
um
the I I think what's going on is the
Saudis are playing this game there's a
chess game and the Saudis are playing a
game here and I think they're trying to
throw some shade on Iran and and take
advantage of the the upheaval and stuff
that's in Iran and I think when people
you know you read your morning newspaper
and you look at stuff and you have to
look at the you know what does the
chessboard look behind this and this is
just a statement nothing has happened
this is a statement this is Tyler you
got thoughts on this
Iran and I think it's they might do
something just to draw a distraction
away from the protests and the riots I
think they're trying to get people's
eyes off the rights and the protests and
let this cool down while they go in and
and forcibly injure a lot of people and
they send the for the the military in
and quell this and I think they're
trying to do something like draw
distraction and and actually I think
they will do a small attack in Saudi
Arabia but again I think it's just a
distraction to to draw away from the
protests and the riots Adam
I sent you something it's it's actually
kind of gives you a more of a clearer
picture on what's happening in the
Middle East it's not so much Iran uh and
Saudi Arabia you know Sunni Shiite we've
all if you're not familiar with that
that's a whole we can go down the whole
Rabbit Hole there but it's sort of like
a a meme and it's two Arab guys kind of
talking and trying to figure it out and
basically goes like this in the middle
in the Middle East today we have the
sunnis who hate the Shia it's right and
then you have the Turks who hate the
Kurds and the Saudis hate the Iranians
and the Palestinians who hate the
Israelis and the yemenis who hate the
Saudis and the Iraqis who hate the
Iranians and the libyans who hate the
Egyptians so the cause of tension in the
Middle East is clear and it could not be
clear it's failure of American
leadership
that's what it is so it's like if you
want to go down the rabbit hole of
what's going on in the Middle East it's
like we just cleared it up yeah
America's fault print this is faults
yeah you know I mean you lived in Iran
so I think you can appreciate this it's
like it's not all just Arabs are
together and they hate UF faster and
they hate you know Israel there's
there's Sunni and their Shiites and
obviously the Turks and the Armenians
have their issues and Azerbaijan and
Russia and this and the old Cold War and
who came in and the Egyptians they have
peace with with Israel and the
jordanians like I think
um Netanyahu who's all up in the news
running for re-election for like the
fifth all of them all up in it yeah um
first of all this artist everybody looks
like Osama Bin Laden I know you know
every single person but somebody asked
me the other day why like why are Middle
East is why you guys have so much like
you know how hot it is can you imagine
going to the beach and never leaving
it's just hot people are angry dude it's
hot well I live in Miami it's just as
hot and nobody no but there's no shade
bro these guys are out in the middle of
the freaking desert bro there's an angry
and hot
I don't understand Israel and starter is
good secret of relationship well they
can afford the air conditioning here's
something that I think they built an
island that looks like a map of the
world yes they were bored we have all
this money spent in what country is that
Dubai Dubai yeah I mean they're just
doing there like we can make it rain
here go ahead what if you put a palm
tree next to it we'll build that next
just to kind of go on the Israel
perspective about Bibi he was on Bill
Maher recently he you know he was on Fox
recently I I like BB a lot
um he said for years and years and years
he kind of threw John Kerry under the
bus here under the Obama Administration
he's like for years and years and years
and years as they're saying if you want
to have peace in the Middle East and
peace with your Arab neighbors you have
to start with the Palestinians you have
to start there and you make peace there
and he's like listen they don't want
peace okay so he goes listen I I don't
not going to make peace with the one
percent and then move on to the 99 he
basically said let me go make peace and
deals with the 99 Arab world and you
look what they've done well the
arrangements and peace treaties whether
it's Egypt Jordan UAE Oman everything
that they've done he's like let me make
peace with the 99 and then we'll go back
to the one percent I thought that was a
very unique perspective because you
constantly hear about
Israel and Palestinians and figuring it
out it's like where's that gotten
anything and he said listen let's move
the ball forward with the rest of the
Arab countries let's make friends you
know we have a lot of common interests a
lot of their common interests have to do
with you know versus Iran everything
against Iran preventing Iran from a
nuclear weapon forget preventing
terrorism in the Middle East and part of
that is this story right here where this
secret relationship between Israel and
Saudi because what's the famous thing we
always talk about the friend or the
enemy of my enemy is my friend everyone
can agree that Iran is pretty much
everyone's enemy in the Middle East
other than certain parts of Syria and
Hezbollah and Lebanon and that kind of
stuff like that Afghanistan but well
well that's a whole nother thing but uh
interesting perspective by Bibi let's
see what happens there's a lot of
tension right now we'll see what
happened here by the article it just
came out by Washington Post
U.S workers have gotten way less
productive no one is sure why oh really
okay now we have no clue because we have
no clue why the employee you know
employees have gotten unproductive you
know in the first half of 2020 to
productivity the measure of how much
output and goods and services an
employee can produce in an hour plunged
by the sharpest raid on record going
back to 1947 according to data from the
Bureau of Labor Statistics it also
raises new questions about the shift to
hybrid schedules and remote work oh
possible questions yeah I mean that's
definitely not that as employees have
made the case that flexibility helped
them work from more effectively and it
comes at a time when quiet quitting
doing only what's expected
and no more is resonating especially
with younger workers no one knows or
will know what is causing the drop-off
in productivity for some time said
Economist Lawrence H Summers president
emmer he's this is this is supposed to
be a smart person here saying
I know I know who he is no he was under
the uh uh
Administration
no one knows or will know why what is
causing the drop off and productivity
for some time said Economist Larry
Summers uh uh but he was a former
treasury secretary but it could have
something to do with the fact that many
employees were working unsustainable
hard in 2020 and 2021. oh my God
Larry the Larry that statement there
there was something missing after a
night of hard drinking with Paul Pelosi
he said but it could have something to
do with the back then pleasure but you
know what's this is BS because which way
does he wasn't does he want to say he he
contradicts himself is quiet quitting
doing what it only what is expected and
more that was the work from home thing
and then he wants to say but they were
working unsustainably hard in 20 years
let me say this you can't use both sides
of his mouth if you're seven years old
if you're seven years old you're 10
years old and your mom's best friend
brings her 10 year old daughter over to
your house your 10 she's 10. and you're
upstairs in your room if your mom and
her mom are okay with you being upstairs
for two hours what do you think
eventually is happening okay well what's
the rule don't close the door don't let
me the kid stay in it so you know don't
let them be by themselves nobody else if
you want to play you guys can play
downstairs in front of us right here
while you're 10 years old you ain't
going upstairs hey Mom hey Dad are you
guys okay if I go in the room with Mary
and close the door and lock it up
because we feel we're gonna be more
productive here Mom yeah go ahead guys
go ahead and close the door and do this
yeah yeah yeah okay we trust you so much
there will be productive for the same
bosses it's not even though they're
going to play what is that game you know
doctor whatever so the point is to the
bosses that actually bought into this
you know to the bosses that actually
bought into this and said oh this is a
very effective method really really like
maybe you want to be less productive
yeah maybe secretly you want to work
from home so you can tell everybody what
to do so you can watch more Netflix so
you can watch do you know how often
nowadays I walk by people right even the
environment here or our insurance
company I'll walk by cubicles you know
how many employees I'll see sometimes
they're just watching a movie while
they're doing their work oh really you
know what yeah I'm sorry about that no
no I'm sitting I'm like I'm like what is
this guy doing oh this is the videos the
videos I don't want to give names
because people are going to go upstairs
I'm like what's this guy doing he's
watching a movie already do oh we had an
editor who would always have mistakes
and things he would do with different I
love this guy yeah but every day he
would watch three movies oh you cannot
stay focused and watch more so if you're
watching movies at work if you're
watching movies at work and you're
watching shows at work what the hell you
think people are doing their home by
themselves you think maybe listen I'm
gonna take a 20 minute nap and unless I
was at the restroom yeah hey babe come
over why I'm just who cares they're not
gonna know anyway just come over let's
spend some time together you know what
I'm gonna go over here on XYZ and have a
cup of coffee and take a three-hour
lunch break I wanna what do you think is
going to be happening so again this is
when
being naive gets exposed and people no
longer use logic to think someone's
going to be more productive at home
every article two years ago year and a
half ago was people are being more
creative and productive working from
home I can't tell you how many
presentations I got from managers that
work with me saying Patrick we're going
to do much better if we get people to
work from home no we're not
no we're not no one is more productive
working from home than be working from
the office now some people are
independent contractors that do what
they do and they're based on projects
and all the fine I'm not talking about
that for the most part there's a reason
why workers have gone less productive
um I'm sure I think there's two sides of
the equation here there's and by the way
yeah go ahead remember a week ago on the
podcast we talked about that software
company where the engineers working from
home path they were using it as cover to
have two jobs
ah so you take eight hours in a day but
I'm paid for 16. I call that 50
productivity right it's pretty people
having two jobs that's simple simple
math two jobs paid 16 hours worked eight
that's fifteen percent I actually
respect those people because they are
busting their ass two jobs we expect I
mean most that's what it is by the way
it is what percentage of people are
doing that that's very creative 99 are
working less but quick shout out to Paul
E I know he's probably uh listening
right now if he's uh and not watching a
movie but there's two sides to this
there's a productivity side but there's
also the culture side of things right
could you imagine if I think that we
here at valuetainment not only are we
creating content and filming stuff and
everything that you see the podcast but
there's also the other side of things
it's the culture that we're creating
it's the teamwork it's the environment
it's the friendships if you're doing
that at your company
and everything's remote there's no
culture there's no teamwork there's no
oh we got this thing going on here once
a month we do team meetings you talked
about uh Lincoln on leadership
circulating the troops and hey man how
you feeling blah blah blah like that's
also a part of a company yeah so it's
um not just the productivity yeah going
with each other cop Golf and getting
outside working you have to do you have
to be in front of the person to find out
by the way listen it's very simple if
you want to work in an environment where
they want to let you work remote those
companies are out there go find them go
find them we're not one it's I'm very
okay with that but for people the same
people that said I don't know why maybe
because they work so hard in 2020 and
2021. I can guarantee you people didn't
work hard in 2020 and 24. it's the least
working years in the last two three four
decades because they got away with
everything working from home and nobody
very few people in 2020 and 2021 were
working harder than they working
if you're working and your bed is right
there the TV's there and the couch is
there yeah and the refrigerator also the
bong is right there they're close by the
alcohol people are coming over you're
doing a zoom with them any reason why
your eyes are so red yeah it's just been
a very stressful day yeah man yeah just
woke up dude you know it's interesting
the news media pushes The Narrative of
workers to the world you and I you know
leave them alone let them work from home
they're gonna be more productive they
put all this as BS was very very
interesting there there was a gentleman
that ran the um the unfortunate
amalgamation of uh Yahoo and AOL that
was bought by Verizon and Pat you know
what he found he found that the recent
college graduates so the ones that were
like less than five years out of college
Pat they were always asking when can I'm
working hard and I'm doing more when can
I get a
oh you can get a raise if I choose to
promote how do I get the promotion and
then they wanted FaceTime with their
boss they wanted to be seen they wanted
to be doing their little meetings and
have their boss walk by and see that
they were working with their team that
didn't work working from home and there
is Beyond The Narrative of the news
media Pat there were people that were
just five years out of school that were
not looking for Kush they were looking
to be seen and they wanted to know how
they got promoted and they want to make
more money because they weren't content
with where they were and nobody wants to
talk about this but this stuff was
happening and you know my hat's off to
them but they don't get coverage yeah
and when he said looking for Kush he
didn't mean marijuana guys amen
let's do this last story here let's do
this last story yeah one in five vets in
uh of U.S adults 20 to 49ers from
excessive drinking study shows this is a
CNN Story the percentage of that's
attributed to alcohol use variated state
varied state by state by nationally it's
a leading cause of preventable death
said lead study author Marissa Esser who
leads the U.S CDC alcohol program States
and communities can prevent these
premature deaths using evidence-based
strategies to reduce availability and
accessibility of alcohol and increase
its price that can mean increasing taxes
on alcohol or limiting where alcohol is
sold Esther added the CDC defines
moderate drinking as two drinks or less
in a day for men or one drink or less
for women two-thirds women why they're
using women isn't it like uh it's
offensive to use but anyway two-thirds
of adults reported report drinking more
than moderate amounts at least once a
month Adam so this is one of those
stories that I had kind of had to read
twice I'm like what is what are they
trying to say here and the first thing I
thought of when they said reduce the
availability and accessibility of
alcohol it's like yeah we tried that one
time before it was called prohibition
how'd that work out yeah not so good
okay that's not gonna happen all right
we're now we're going to start
increasing the taxes on alcohol
price top
increasing taxes and alcohol and
limiting where alcohol sold it's like
how many like like I mean I've been in
The Nightlife business and and I go out
all that kind of stuff like that it's
like you go to a liquor store what's the
average bottle cost 30 40 50 bucks okay
now if you want to go buy that same
exact bottle of Club that's gonna cost
you 300 400 500 bucks if you want to buy
it per drink that's 10 12 bucks per
drinkers it's like whatever you do to go
and try to figure out the price or the
cost of the taxes like people are gonna
drink you're not gonna figure that out
people are not going to stop drinking
people are not going to stop partying by
the way especially during a recession
hello
whatever ideas you have to limit people
from drinking not gonna happen however
let me give it the other side of coin
where I think that this this idea can be
implemented is harsher penalties for
DUIs
it amazes me I live in South Beach it
amazes me that there is not a DUI
checkpoint every single weekend leaving
South Beach it's it's [ __ ] sitting
ducks right there you have no idea how
many people are drinking so you could
drink as much as you want party shot I
don't give a [ __ ] but if you get behind
a wheel of a car Nigel got a problem man
okay because if you drive a car now
you're endangering others obviously
we're all familiar with mad Mothers
Against Drunk Driving
like you should have to pay the price
because you selfishly wanted to party
have a good time and now you're
endangering other people we all know
people that have gotten DUIs pulled over
but it's so puzzling these days when you
see a Paul Pelosi get a DUI when you see
a Tiger Woods get a DUI you see Justin
Bieber Lindsay Lohan famous DUIs out
there it's like have you not heard of
uber guys yeah like what are we talking
about here like the average person these
days can spend 20 30 40 50 bucks on an
Uber not going to be a problem now
you're talking Millionaires and
billionaires who are not willing to get
a goddamn uh Uber yeah it's insane to me
so harsher penalties for DUIs but you're
not going to limit people drinking you
never you don't think there's another
way to go with the study though like
that's a very small number of people
this says I think it said one in one in
six people are binge drinking the study
includes deaths with vehicular accidents
but including alcohol poisoning and
other health impacts such as liver
disease we just came off record high
overdoses right Americans are overdosing
they're drinking too much they're
overweight everybody's on Xanax
everybody's on Zofran or whatever
antidepressants when are leadership and
leaders are going to wake up and say
that there's something wrong with
American that we've lost our way that
we're not happy we're unhealthy we're
drinking ourselves to death we're
overdosing on drugs we're taken to like
you know
there's something other than just people
going out and partying on a Friday night
right people are depressed they're lost
their mental health sucks covet didn't
help cover didn't help yeah I mean if
you want to thank you very much thank
you very much opioid crisis with
drinking and now you're talking about
two different problems that become one
obviously that gets ridiculously way
worse look you know there's two ways to
look at look at problems there's
Upstream problems and downstream
problems and what you just quickly
pointed out the Upstream problem and
I've said this before here's an example
a small lake is polluted the downstream
problem is let's charge all the people
in this community 10 million dollars to
build a giant filter and clean a lake
now the Upstream problem is why don't we
go up the stream and find out what's
polluting the lake and we find that
there's a campground and there's ashes
there's a lot of other things going on
up there and we say bye if we just do a
few things up here we won't be putting
crap in the Stream and it won't be
polluting the lake that is correcting an
upstream problem this is a classic
Downstream story States and communities
can prevent these using reduce the
availability let's call it alcohol
control it's like gun control we if we
control the guns we control the alcohol
we increase the price of it we do all
that that's Downstream the question is
why are the people drinking why is there
the demand for it or why are there you
know mentally deranged people getting
their hands on a firearm those people
shouldn't have a firearm Upstream you
brought it up the Upstream problem is is
America is a stressed out overweight
place and you know being aware and
helping your friends and I identify that
is how I deal with the Upstream problem
when I see friends or family that I
think are over stressed or there because
I don't want them to self-medicate I
don't want to do other things and so
it's a good point your points could be
exactly right
that's a good point good commentary so
you know let's go to the last one and in
regards to DUIs by the way uh the
solution for not having one have a
person with you use Uber a lot of
feedback you give with Lyft now there's
no excuse for not having a DUI today
when I was in the army Sergeant told us
very simple if you guys going to go out
to the club and party someone's got to
be sober and God knows how many times
that rule was broken luckily none of us
we didn't get a DUI but other additional
challenges did take place especially
when companies like Budweiser are
offering free Designated Drivers yeah
forget about that it's just I won't do
this last story for two minutes before
we wrap up we got the Dream Team call
here FCC commissioner says government
should ban Tick Tock okay the Council on
Foreign investment in the U.S should
take action on Tick Tock Brandon Carr
one of five Commissioners at the Federal
Trade Commission with more than 200
million downloads in the us alone the
popular app has become in a form of
critical information infrastructure
making the apps ownership by the Chinese
patent company a target of grow National
Security concern China's based engineer
is working at Tick Tock addressed
non-public U.S user information
including phone numbers and birthdays
and BuzzFeed reported in June bite dance
which is the based in China instructed
employees to push probation messaging to
U.S users of a news app BuzzFeed
reported in July bite then's planned to
use tick tock collect information about
U.S certain U.S users according to
Forbes report published last month let
me say this part here I have zero trust
in this company I have zero trust in
their management team I have zero trust
I created an account on Tick Tock and
I'm going to tell you openly here the
only reason I did is to give the things
I believe in on the people on Tick Tock
that are not being heard so I was
talking and you know China I was talking
capitals anything that they don't
support I was talking about it
and it gradually uh you saw what
messages they didn't like we did one
video on China prior to that I did the
numbers the other day with Kai the prior
100 videos I think some 10 of them got a
million views five of them got five
million views but should have got a
hundred thousand views prior hundred the
moment I clicked put a video about China
after that 400 videos on Tick Tock only
one of them got over a hundred thousand
views zero over 50 000 views 400 videos
of those 400 on Instagram they all
performed okay but only one got over a
hundred thousand views it's the Antonio
Brown clip Tick Tock is a gamified
company uh I'm we're still posting stuff
because we want them to be held
accountable on what they're doing but
this company is one president away from
being banned in America the current
president doesn't have the audacity to
do it because he's he needs those 1918
new tick tockers that are making videos
saying good things about him if he bans
Tick Tock game over but the next
president's going to have the audacity
Tick Tock is one president away from
being banned in America it can happen in
2024-22. that Tyler made a great point
on my podcast because we're talking
about all these challenges the Kia
challenge where you just steal a key and
kids are crashing and dying and you know
the tide pod Challenge and you were
saying it they're dumbing the NyQuil
challenge the knife challenge they're
making our youth and not only the
attention span this short but dude
they're literally making our kids poison
themselves to kill themselves and it's
like well um someone's Revenge a leader
eventual is going to have the audacity
to shut him down I can't wait for that
day I gotta wrap up quick thought just
on this what's the name of the Chinese
TV station in America where you can
watch all the Chinese stuff
[ __ ] it doesn't exist is my point I was
just like okay media is a thing that
countries use to control uh narratives
in in populations social media is even
more
precise and the algorithms that social
media can do can Target you you know all
day who to Target what to say there's no
reason that Tick Tock Chicago got a wrap
up gotta wrap up listen folks if you
enjoyed this give us a sub if you want
to be at our 500 000 subscriber
celebration live sub and I would say
send us a text message at 3104 uh three
one zero three four three uh do you know
the number give me the number three one
zero three four zero one one three two
one more time three one zero three four
zero one one three two text us and put
podcast text us and put the word podcast
will add you to a list the moment we're
selling tickets for the live podcast
you're gonna get a text but text us one
more time the correct number since I
butchered it at first three one zero
three four zero one one three two send
us a text if you want to be added to the
list of the first live podcast I think
it's going to be limited to 100 or 200
seats but we're looking forward to you
have you joining us on our 500 000
subscriber celebration on the podcast
take care everybody have a great weekend
bye bye bye